la séance est
ouverte le contte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué nous
n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois
point le procèsverbal est donc adopté
sous les réserves
d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les
ministres Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
d'Israël mes chers
collègues le 7 octobre au
matin le Hamas a déclenché une opération
terroriste de grande ampleur sur le sol
israélien se la désolation et la mort
engendra un climat de terreur qui n'a
d'égal que la cruauté dont les
terroristes islamistes du Hamas ont fait
preuve à l'égard des
victimes pour Israël et les démocraties
allons pas douter il y aura un avant et
un après le 7 octobre
2023 comme il y eu un avant et un après
le 11 septembre 2001 et un avant et un
après cette terrible année 2015
dans notre pays la France
rappelons-nous pour nous
Français le massacre du
Bataclan trouve un échot
singulier dans le massacre de jeunes
israéliens que la musique avait
réuni
rappelons-nous les rues de Paris
parcouru par les terroristes s'apparente
étrangement aux rues et routes des
villes et de certains kibous
aujourd'hui dans un deuil
profond
rappelons-nous partout des assassinats
des
otage et l'odieux chantage qui pèse sur
leur
vie mais en
Israël c'est toute une armée terroriste
qui a déferlé puissante organisée
soutenue par des pays
étranger donnant à cette attaque une
ampleur
inédite
les massaces commis dans les kibut de
Berry et ont un nom des crimes contre
l'humanité
rappelons-nous l'État d'Israël était au
premier rang en 2015 au premier rang des
soutiens apportés à la France le
président de la clette m'avait alors
écrit je cite sa lettre la France
blessée fait saigner le cœur
d'Israël pu la France aujourd'hui être
la plus
fervante au côté des
Israéliens en cet
instant il convient de penser aux
victimes israéliennes et à celles
d'autres nationalités notamment à nos
compatriotes à leurs familles à leurs
proches à ceux qui aujourd'hui encore
sont portés disparu ou qui enlevé ont
été violentés et pris en
otage nous
exigeons la libération immédiate et sans
condition de tous les
otages ceux qui les détiennent seront
tenus responsables de leur
vie j'ai exprimé en votre non à tous
oui à tous mes chers collègues la
solidarité du Sénat en écrivant au
président de l'État
d'israëlzog et au président de la
cissette notre collègue
Oana mais je souhaiterais que d'un seul
mouvement nous puissions
ensemble manifester notre détermination
à nous tenir auprès du peuple
d'Israël peuple meurtri traumatisé
affaibli peut-être mais valeureux
portant haut des valeurs qui sont les
nôtres celles de la démocratie
parlementaire et de la liberté un pleup
en un mot
inébronlable je vous
invite à vous lever pour observer une
minute de silence vous étiez debout mais
je voulais vous le redire parce que il y
a un moment où nous devons nous élever
tous
ensemble
donner la parole à madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur d'Israël mesdames
et messieurs les
sénateurs alors que des attaques
terroristes effroyables ont touché
l'État
d'Israël je veux au nom de mon
gouvernement dire toute ma solidarité et
mon soutien au peuple Israël
en chaque jour nous découvrons de
nouvelles horreurs commises par les
terroristes du
Hamas chaque jour le bilan s'alourdit et
je veux redire solennellement avant
toute chose que rien jamais ne peut
justifier le
terrorisme aujourd'hui je pense aux
victimes et j'exprime la compassion de
la France à leurs famille et à leurs
proches alors que le bilan vient une
nouvelle fois de
s'alourdir je veux avoir un mot
particulier pour nos 10 ressortissants
décédés et les 18 dont nous sommes sans
nouvelles dans ce moment tragique je
sais l'émotion et l'angoisse qui
saisissent les Français vivants en
Israël et les
franco-israéliens nous sommes avec eux
et nos services diplomatiques mettent
tout en œuvre pour les
accompagn mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le président de la République
l'a dit avec force nous sommes au côté
d'Israël pays alliés de la France qui
vit un drame terrible je vous
remercie merci madame la Première
ministre chers collègues je vous
invite à vous
lever mes chers
collègues l'émotion qui a suivi la
disparition brutale de victoire jasmin
montre l'estime dont elle bénéficiait
tant dans notre assemblée qu'en
Guadeloupe c'est en 2008 que sa carrière
politique débute avec son élection au
conseil municipal de mornalo dont elle
devint un premier adjoint au maire
elle est réélue en
2014 puis en
2020 2017
elle est élue sénatrice de la Guadeloupe
au sein de notre ha assemblée elle
intègre le groupe socialiste écologiste
et républicain son groupe et tout
naturellement la commission des affaires
sociales la conviction la générosité et
l'engagement avec lesquel elle exerce
son mandat de sénatrice sont à la
hauteur de la conception exigeante
qu'elle a de sa mission en faveur de son
territoire et de ceux qui
l'habit femme de terrain
chaleureuse enthousiaste elle demeure
constamment à l'écoute de ses
concitoyens femme de combat résolument
de gauche elle inscrit son action autour
des principes de la République la
liberté l'égalité la fraternité femme de
dossier les scrupuleus et déterminé
animé par un idéal de justice apprécié
reconnu par ses collègues ces travaux
firent honneur à notre assemblée je
pense en particulier au rapport sur les
risques naturels majeurs dans les outr M
ou sur la parentalité dans les outres
mers rapport récent dont elle était
co-auteur
elle savait concilier vie familiale vie
associative vie politique vie
professionnelle de multiples entre
guillemets casquettes qui l'incite à
lutter en faveur de la valorisation de
la femme dans une société plus
égalitaire victoire intervient également
sur de nombreux textes législatifs
déposera au cours de son mandat beaucoup
d'amendements don certains comme celui
de la prise en charge des tests
clordécon sur les humains un véritable
sujet aux Antilles ont été adopté à
l'unanimité je le rappelle par le
Sénat enfin j'ai pu mesurer lors des
réunions du Bureau du Sénat où elle
était secrétaire du
l'énergie déployée en sa qualité de
secrétaire pour assumer ses
responsabilités en particulier au côté
de notre collègue Pascal gruni lors de
la réflexion menée pour renforcer le
contrôle
parlementaire au
moment son corps va être
transporté vers sa terre natale son île
à laquelle elle était tant attachée je
voulais que au nom du Sénat tout entier
nous assurions de notre profonde
sympathie nous les avons rencontré hier
soir ses enfants sa petite fille
l'ensemble de la famille et ses proches
et je vous propose de partager je la
vois encore ici dans cet hémicycle là en
face je vous propose de partager un
moment de souvenir et de
recueillement
merci
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement je
vous rappelle que notre séance est
retransmise en direct sur Public Sénat
et sur notre
site chacun d'entre vous mes chers
collègues sera attentif au cours de nos
échanges
à respecter l'une des valeurs
essentielle du Sénat le respect qu'il
s'agisse du respect des uns et des
autres mais aussi plus prosaïquement
c'est essentiel le respect du temps de
parole je vais donner la parole au
président Patrick canner pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Madame
la première
ministre merci au président Larcher tout
d'abord pour ses paroles de
solidarité nous avons le cœur brisé pour
les victimes et leur famille et une
pensée particulière pour nos
compatriotes qui ont perdu la vie ou qui
ont été pris en otage nous n'avons plus
de mots et pourtant tout est dit tout
est dit dans l'article 15 de la Charte
du Hamas je cite face à l'usurpation de
la Palestine par les Juifs il faut
brandir l'étandard du djihad les scènes
insoutenable dans les kibousim de karaza
et de Berry raisonneront à jamais dans
la mémoire du peuple israélien comme
pour nous les morts de Charlie de
l'hyercacher du Bataclan ou de la
Promenade des Anglais rafle porome choix
par balle décapitation au couteau de
femmes et d'enfants relève sans nul
doute d'une volonté
génocidaire alors oui comme daesh le
Hezbolah le Djihad islamique ou bokaram
le ramasse est bien une organisation
terroriste une filiale de la mort
ne pas ne pas clairement le reconnaître
sous couvert d'explication vaseuses
relève de
l'indignité alors
oui alors
oui quel autre État de droit Israël a le
droit de se défendre il doit le faire
dans le respect des conventions
internationales alors oui le Sénat le
Sénat le Hamas excusez-moi monsieur le
Président alors oui le
Hamas SIME la terreur et le ramasse à
horreur de nos valeurs démocratie
liberté d'expression
laïcité droit des femmes à disposer
d'elles-même ce prosélitisme de
l'obscurantisme qui touche de manière
protéiforme toute la planète doit être
dénoncé et combattu l'Union européenne
est-elle vraiment au niveau pour relever
le défi alors oui le ramas combat toutes
ses forces de toutes ses forces toute
idée de paix symbolisée aujourd'hui par
les accords d'Abraham il faut aider le
peuple palestinien de Gaza à se libérer
des tyrans qui le poussent dans une
impasse mortifère les progressistes des
deux peuples doivent être encouragés
accompagnés défendus deux états pour une
paix durable il faut retrouver l'esprit
des accords d'Oslo madame la Première
ministre vous avez indiqué à l'Assemblée
nationale que la France tiendrait toute
sa place et ferait tout pour trouver une
solution politique quelles sont les
initiatives précises que vous comptez
engager mes chers collègues soutenir le
peuple israélien aujourd'hui dans le
drame indissible qu'il subit c'est
défendre une certaine idée de
l'humanité
merci merci monsieur le
président madame la Première ministre
pour vous
répondre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs les
sénateurs monsieur le Président Patrick
canner tout d'abord je veux à mon tour
rendre hommage à la sénatrice victoire
jasmin disparu la semaine dernière par
ses combats et ses engagements c'était
une figure forte et de notre vie
politique en Guadeloupe comme au Sénat
au nom du gouvernement je tenais à lui
rendre
hommage vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président samedi dernier l'horreur du
terrorisme a frappé
Israël depuis samedi chaque jour de
nouvelles monstruosités commises par les
terroristes du Hamas et du Djihad
islamique sont
découvertes et au tir de roquettes aux
enlèvements y compris de personnes âgés
et d'enfants se sont ajoutés une série
de massacres lors d'un festival à l'est
de Gaza ou dans les kibuts de Berry et
de kfarasa et vous avez dit monsieur le
Président combien ces drames font écho à
d'autres drames survenu sur le
territoire
national
l'horreur c'est le seul mot qui convient
pour décrire ces attaques terroristes et
notre soutien doit être total au nom du
gouvernement je dire à nouveau toute ma
solidarité envers le peuple israélien
envers les victimes leurs familles et
leurs proches je veux avoir une pensée
particulière pour les victimes
françaises et pour nos compatriotes
disparus dont la situation est
extrêmement
préoccupante parmi eux plusieurs enfants
probablement enlevés nous sommes en lien
constant avec les famille je veux
adresser toutes mes pensées à la
Communauté française en Israël qui V
dans l'angoisse le Centre de Crise du
quai d'orsé et notre ambassade sont
pleinement mobilisés pour les
accompagner par ailleurs nous
travaillons activement au côté
d'airfrance pour que des solutions de
retour soient proposées à tous nos
ressortissants qui le souhaite un vol
spécial a d'ors et déjà été confirmé
demain et nous travaillons à différentes
options jusqu'à la reprise des vol
régulier nous soutenons Israël dans
cette épreuve et comme l'a fait le
présid ident de la République je le dis
sans
ambiguité face au terrorisme Israël a le
droit de se défendre face à la barbarie
personne ne peut remettre en cause ce
droit je veux aussi dire aux Juifs de
France choqués par cette attaque et
inquiet par ses répercussions sur notre
sol national que nous sommes à leur côté
l'antisémitisme n'a pas sa place en
France l'antisémitisme n'a pas sa place
dans la
République sémitisme est un délit nous
ne laisserons rien passer le ministre de
l'Intérieur a immédiatement passé des
consignes de vigilance aux forces de
l'ordre et au préfet afin notamment de
renforcer la protection des lieux les
plus
sensibles monsieur le Président canner
la France n'oublie pas son histoire et
sa responsabilité pour la paix nous
devons tout faire pour éviter
l'embrasement de la région permettre la
désescalade la protection des civil et
le respect du droit international c'est
le sens des échanges constants que mène
le président de la République et la
ministres des Affaires étrangères avec
leurs homologues depuis les
attaques monsieur le Président canner
dans un tel moment nous avons le devoir
collectivement de faire vivre les
valeurs de la République et de défendre
la cohésion
nationale je me réjouis de voir que dans
cette assemblée cette conviction est
partagée par toutes et tous s exception
je vous
remercie merci madame la Première
ministre je vais donner la parole à
notre collègue Robert
R pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologiste kanaki chers
collègues vous avez la parole pour la
première fois je crois dans cet
hémicycle merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'intérieur des are mère
c'est la première fois que je m'exprime
devant cette assemblée je voudrais le
faire avec respect et humilité avec le
peuple français que vous représentez le
peuple canak n'est pas l'ennemi du
peuple français il veut mettre fin à une
histoire coloniale de 170 ans le
gouvernement a remis le 6 septembre 2023
un document présenté comme un projet
d'accord et qui aurait vocation à être
le support d'une révision de la
Constitution ce texte commence par dire
que le peuple calédonien a manifesté sa
volonté que la Nouvelle-Calédonie reste
dans la France je rappelle qu'au 3è
référendum 56 % des Calédoniens se sont
abstenus don plus de 80 90 % de can le
peuple calédonien sans le peuple Canac
n'existe pas disait l'historien
calédonien José barbasson ce résultat
est contesté devant l'un que dit ce
document d'abord il abandonne toute
trajectoire de colonisation le
référendum envisagés visent à refaire
accepter un statut d'autonomie dans la
France prétexte à la désinscription de
notre pays de la liste des territoires
décolonisés il vise ensuite à se
substituer à l'accord de Nea en lui
faisant perd sa valeur constitutionnelle
il veut enfire ouvrir le périmètre du
peuple calédonien aux arrivants ayant 10
ans de résidence un cor électoral
glissant légitime la colonie du
peuplement ce qui est contraire aux
résolutions de l'ONU aux équilibres
négociés en 98 le manque d'impartialité
amène aujourd'hui un débat stérile il
est nécessaire que l'État puisse
comprendre que le temps du palable est
un temps de sagesse monsieur le ministre
ma question est la suivante sans
consensus le gouvernement compte-il
contre l' viis du flkss et comme au 3è
référendum passer en force cette
révision constitutionnelle ou
envisage-t-il de présenter lors de
latéral décolonisation un nouveau
document qui se situerait enfin dans la
continuité historique de l'accord de nè
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur
rou que je cherche pardon
voilà à nouveau la Nouvelle-Calédonie
est à un moment important de son
histoire il s'agit à l'issue du
processus politique prévu par l'accord
de numea de dessiner son avenir
institutionnel au cours des derniers
mois le président de la République et le
gouvernement se sont employés à créer
les conditions d'un dialogue serein et
constructif avec les indépendantistes et
les non
indépendantistes lors de sa visite en
Nouvelle-Calédonie fin juillet dernier
le président de la République a proposé
à chacun le pacte de N
autour de deux chemins le pardon et
l'avenir sur cette base il a invité les
acteurs politiques à travailler à la
recherche de consensus sur chaque
sujet début septembre une semaine de
discussion s'est tenue à Paris à mon
invitation j'ai réuni l'ensemble des
acteurs à Matignon le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outr mèes a organisé
plusieurs réunions avec les
délégations la conclusion de cette
discussion tour du président de la
République et avec toutes les parties a
permis de faire le bilan de ces échanges
et de tracer les perspectives
perspective pour la recherche d'un
accord dans les tous prochains mois et
au terme de ces échanges tous non
indépendantist comme indépendantiste se
sont engagés à poursuivre les
discussions sur la base d'un projet
d'accord que le ministre de l'Intérieur
et des outremes Gérald armanin vient de
transmettre au partis ce document est
une base de travail il appartient au
partis de formuler leurs propositions
concrètes le gouvernement souhaite
parvenir à un accord d'ici la fin de
l'année ceci suppose néanmoins que tous
participent aux discussions animées par
la volonté
d'aboutir le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des outremèes se rendra à nouveau en
Nouvelle-Calédonie fin octobre le moment
venu le gouvernement proposera
présentera un projet de révision
constitutionnelle pour tirer les
conséquences de l'accord trouvé cette
révision devra notamment permettre le
dégel du corps électoral des élections
provinciales qui est une exigence
démocratique comme l'Accord de numea en
1998 le projet d'accord sera soumis à
l'approbation de la population
calédonienne et une fois l'accord entré
en vigueur les élections provinciales
seront organisées il s'agit de pouvoir
organiser ce rendez-vous démocratique il
s'agit aussi d'avancer et comme l'a dit
le président de la République nous
n'avons pas le droit d'attendre c'est
l'avenir que nous sommes en train de
construire celui de la jeunesse
calédonienne celui de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie dans la République je
vous
remercie merci la parole est
maintenant au président Hervé Marseille
pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste monsieur le Président Madame
la première ministre mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
à mon tour au nom de mon groupe je
voudrais m'associer au président
l'archer dans ses propos vis-à-vis
d'Israël et nous tenons bien sûr au côté
d'Israël dans cette épreuve notre
continent notre vieux continent depuis
des siècles a connu bien des guerres des
massacres des prommes des charniers des
horreurs de toutes sortes nous pensions
avoir
atteint le bout de ces horreurs dans ce
que nous avons entendu vu et puis
finalement un degré supplémentaire a été
perpétré en Israël le 7 octobre avec
l'incursion des tueurs du Hamas des
hommes des femmes des vieillards des
bébés
décapités on navait jamais vu ça c'est
un abilissement cela a été dit par le
président canner de la civilisation
l'humanité c'est insupportable on ne
trouve plus les mots j'ai cherché
moi-même les mots que je pouvais
employer on ne trouve plus les mots
c'est tu parce que certains voudraient
nous faire croire qu'il s'agit de
résistants on n jamais vu des résistants
qui tuaient des enfants des jeunes des
jeunes hommes et des jeunes femmes dans
une rêveptie ou qui décapit des bébés on
na jamais vu ça ce sont des tueurs tout
simplement et ces tueurs ils sortent pas
de nulle part ils ont été accompagnés
ils ont été aidés entraînés financés et
on sait par qui on sait par qui par le
Qatar puisque le chef des tueurs est
héberger au Qatar monsieur anier est au
Qatar C même qui finance ici le PSG ou
d'autres grandes
entreprises et
puis et puis il y a l'Iran et nous avons
été très conciliant vis-à-vis de l'Iran
dans le dossier nucléaire en particulier
pour rechercher des solutions parce que
nous pensions que c'était important pour
la paix dans le monde et pour la région
alors madame la Première ministre
question est simple quelles conséquences
le gouvernement tire-t-il de
l'implication de ces deux pays dans les
relations avec ces pays et quelles
actions entendons-nous prendre en France
pour mettre un terme à leur implication
dans ces meurtres barbares je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est à Madame la premierre
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le président Hervé
Marseille l'attaque terroriste commise
par le Hamas contre
Israël est odieuse vous l'avez dit
inqualifiable un groupe terroriste s'en
est pris à des civils dans un déluge de
roquettes de violence dans une
multiplication ignoble d'actes de
barbarie des femmes des hommes des
personnes âgées des jeunes et des
enfants parfois même des bébés ont été
pris pour cible et comme toutes les
démocraties nous sommes au côté d'Israël
dans ces moments
terribles vous m'interrogez sur le rôle
de certains États dans cette
action d'abord avec l'ensemble de la
communauté
internationale nous appelons tous les
États à condamner ces actes terroristes
aucun gouvernement ne peut rester
insensible face à ces
images s'agissant de l'Iran en
particulier le président de la
République a eu l'occasion de s'exprimer
hier nous n'avons pas de preuve formelle
de l'implication de l'Iran nous
consolidons nos analyses avec nos
partenaires ce qui est clair c'est le
caractère inacceptable des images de
triomphalisme ou de certains propos des
autorités iranienne il n'y a aucune
ambiguïé possible je condamne comme vous
avec la plus grande fermeté les pays qui
se sont félicités de cette attaque
terroriste
monstrueuse face à la gravité de la
situation nous agissons et nous agirons
en
responsabilité nous soutenons le droit
d'Israël à se défendre contre le
terrorisme sous l'gide du président de
la République la diplomatie est à
l'œuvre pour éviter l'embrasement et
l'escalade dans la région nous sommes en
contact étroit avec nos partenaires pour
que la communauté internationale fasse
la lumière sur ses événements et le rôle
des uns et des autres nous rappelons que
les civils doivent être protégés et le
droit international respecté nous
soutenons toujours une solution
politique au conflit israélo-palestinien
notre position n'a pas changé nous
agissons également avec nos partenaires
européens la coordination entre les
États-membres doit être entière et hier
s'est tenue une réunion informelle des
27 ministres des Affaires étrangères de
l'Union européenne monsieur le Président
Marseille nous sommes au côté du peuple
israélien et avec nos partenaires nous
travaillons à identifier toutes les
responsabilités dans cette attaque
inacceptable je vous
remercie la parole est maintenant au
président Gontard pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et
territoire merci merci monsieur le
président madame la Première ministre
depuis samedi nos cœurs sont étreints
par l'attaque terroriste injustifiable
et sans précédent opéré par le Hamas sur
le territoire
d'Israël nous condamnons avec la plus
grande fermeté la barbarie qui s'est
déchaîné contre les populations civiles
oui effectivement il n'y a pas de mot au
victimes de ces actes abjects aux étages
détenus à Gaza dont nous demandons la
libération à leurs famillees leurs
proches au peuple d'Israël à son
ambassadeur et à ses amis à travers le
monde nous témoignons notre profonde
émotion et notre
solidarité nous déplorons avec la même
émotion le nouveau cycle de violence
aveugle qui s'est vit au proche- Orient
et qui a déjà fait plusieurs milliers de
victimes israéliennes et palestiniennes
du jamais vu depuis la guerre du Kipour
nous craignons l'embrasement de toute la
région nous portons la conviction qu'une
nouvelle guerre contre la terreur ne
renforcera en aucune façon la sécurité
d'Israël à laquelle nous sommes
profondément attachés depuis 75 ans la
violence ne résout rien il est impératif
d'en sortir au plus vite pour ce là le
blocus de Gaza dont l'ONU vient de
rappeler l'illégalité doit être levé et
l'aide humanitaire préservée les
palestinienses et les Palestiniens ne
peuvent plus être déshumanisés comme l'a
fait le ministre israélien de la Défense
l'an dernier je me suis rendu à Gaza en
sis-jordanie et en Israël avec une
délégation de la commission des affaires
étrangères nous déplorions déjà
l'inaction de la France de l'Union
européenne et de la commité
internationale nous y formulions
plusieurs propositions pour bâtir une
paix durable entre les peuples seul à
même de préserver la sécurité d'Israël
paix durable qui passera nécessairement
par le strict respect du droit
international et l'abandon de la
colonisation madame la Première ministre
pour participer à la construction d'une
solution diplomatique pour permettre un
cesser le feu et la paix la France doit
garder comme boussole absolue le respect
du droit international alors madame la
Première ministre quel sera vre
politique
merci madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le Président Guillaume
Gontard aujourd'hui face aux attaques
terroriste mené par le Hamas et le
Djihad islamique Israël traverse un
drame épouvantable et notre solidarité
envers le peuple israélien est total
face à une attaque d'une telle ampleur
et une telle horreur
Israël a le droit de se défendre
personne ne peut le contester c'est la
position de toutes les démocraties c'est
la conviction de la France car nous
soutiendrons toujours la liberté et la
lutte contre le
terrorisme évidemment dans un tel
contexte la France est extrêmement
active et vigilante pour veiller à la
désescalade éviter l'embrasement de la
région s'assurer de la protection des
civils et du respect du droit
nationale ces derniers jours le
président de la République a multiplié
les contacts avec nos partenaires dans
la région la ministre des Affaires
étrangères a fait de même avec ses
homologues chacun doit mesurer les
risques de la
situation monsieur le Président Gontard
la France a toujours défendu et cherché
le chemin de la paix nous restons fidèle
à cet engagement historique le Hamas ne
veut pas la paix c'est un groupe
terroriste antisémite meurtriers dont le
seul but est d'anéantir l'État d'Israël
nous détourner du processus de paix ce
serait donneré une victoire aux
terroristes notre position n'a pas varié
la France recherchera toujours une paix
durable et une solution politique dans
le conflit
israélo-palestinien nous n'y sommes pas
le chemin sera long mais rien ne doit
nous détourner de cette ambition c'est
la seule qui permettra la stabilité et
la sécurité dans la région je vous
remercie la parole est au président
carucci pour le groupe les
républicains madame la Première
ministre mal nommé les choses c'est
ajouté au malheur du monde disait Albert
Camu nous sommes la France héritière des
philosophes de la Révolution française
et de la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme
du Conseil National de la Résistance de
Léon Bloom et du général de
GA nous sommes le pays porteur de la
liberté de la tolérance de
l'universalité ça veut dire madame la
Première ministre que nous avons une
responsabilité éminente nous ne pouvons
pas faire pardon madame la ministre des
Affaires étrangères des déclarations
uniquement type K dorsé surfiche ou
pas
nous sommes là pour dire simplement
l'empathie n'est pas exclusive de
l'action politique nous sommes là pour
vous dire qu'il faut utiliser les mots
crime contre l'humanité c'est la réalité
ce mot cette expression utilisz là
faites-la utiliser par l'Europe
franchement vu ce qui s'est passé crime
contre l'humanité c'est bien le minimum
la la légitime défense de l'État
d'Israël c'est un droit permanent quand
vous recevez des milliers de de missiles
et que vous assistez à ce qui s passé
dans les kibout légitime défense c'est
le minimum et faites en sorte madame la
Première ministre que celles et ceux qui
dans la République trahissent les
valeurs de la République trahissent les
valeurs de la nation en ne soutenant pas
l'état d'Israël et en faisant l'apologie
du terrorisme
faites en sorte qu'il soit sévèrement
[Applaudissements]
puni est à Madame la Ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
madame Colona merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
je ne voudrais pas en venir à penser que
vous n'avez pas bien entendu le
président de la République Monsieur le
Sénateur madame la Première ministre je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas imaginé que vous
fassiez attention à mes propos madame la
Première ministre vient de rappeler
toute l'horreur que nous inspire les
actes barbares qui ont été commis par le
Hamas et de dire de redire la
condamnation absolu par la France de ces
actes terroristes commis par un groupe
terroriste le Hamas soutenu par d'autres
groupes terroristes et de plus les
prises de Tage abjectent les assassinats
monstrueux les massacres ne laissent
aucun doute sur la nature terroriste du
Hamas notre condamnation est donc total
et absolu et ceci depuis le premier jour
Monsieur le Sénateur face à l'horreur
nous sommes solidaires d'Israël et du
peuple israélien et nous disons avec
force qu'Israël a le droit de se
défendre nous l'avons dit publiquement
depuis le premier jour nous le redisons
nous le disons à tous nos interlocuteurs
dans la région et ailleurs et dans le
même temps oui la première ministre le
disait la responsabilité diplomatique de
la France est aussi d'éviter
l'embrasement dans la région l'Autorité
palestinienne a un rôle à jouer à cet
égard nous continuons à la soutenir le
président de la République s'est exprimé
sur ce point très clairement hier la
diplomatie française est aussi active
pour que la situation de s'aggrave pas à
la frontière avec le Liban je ne doute
pas que vous suiviez avec attention ce
qui s'y passe comme à la frontière avec
la Syrie le président de la République
et moi-même avons multiplié les contacts
depuis samedi avec nos homologues
Israéliens Palestiniens dans la région
européens et bien au-delà et bien sûr
comme l'a dit madame la Première
ministre quand le calme sera revenu il
faudra se demander comment mieux prendre
en compte les aspiration du peuple
palestinien comment mieux répondre au
droit absolu d'Israël à la sécurité la
paix doit rester notre impératif même si
d'évidence ce moment n'est pas
venu monsieur
[Applaudissements]
carucci la parole est au président
François patria pour le groue du
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et
indépendants monsieur le Président
Madame la première ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'heure est à la gravité
l'heure est au recueillement l'heure est
à l'unité d'heure en heure depuis samedi
l'oreur monte à son comble vous êtes
plusieurs monsieur le Président la
première ministre vous mes chers
collègues avoir dit votre colère et
votre émotion bien entendu nous la
partageons tous tous les témoignages qui
nous parviennent de l'attaque terroriste
perpétré par le Hamas contre les civils
israéliens mais aussi étrangers nous
bouleverse et nous révolte tous des
spectacles de car des sommets de
l'horreur ont été atteints des femmes
violées puis exécuté des hommes
décapités des cadavres souillés et
calcinés des enfants victime innocent de
cette folie barbare cette folie elle
raisonne durement pour nous qui avons
connu le terrorisme islamiste elle nous
rappelle daesh al-qïda Boko Haram vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président aussi
au peuple israélien nous affirmons haut
et fort notre solidarité sans faille une
fois encore ce sont les civils qui on
payent le prix fort j'ai une pensée
toute particulière pour nos compatriotes
qui ont perdu dans ce drame pour les
otages français donù nous espérons le
retour et bien sûr à leur familles je
pense aussi à nos concitoyens établis
sur place à cet égard nous souhaitons
vivement remercier notre personnel
diplomatique et consulaire qui a
pleinement mobilisé dans cette crise je
pense également aux Palestiniens pris en
otage par le Hamas qui s'en servent de
boucliers humain et qui pont le prix du
sang à la place des lâches qui tirent
sur des femmes des enfants et des hommes
sans défense à ceux qui soutenant le
Hamas et pensent soutenir les
Palestiniens nous disons que cette
aveuglement idéologique ne fait
qu'ajouter à leur malheur le monde
s'embrase les foyers de guerre se
multiplient et alors que nos yeux sont
tournés vers l'Ukraine le haut carabac
voici un douloureux rappel de
l'instabilité du Proche Orient 30 ans
après la signature des accords d'oselo
le Hamas a décidé de réveiller les
démons de la guerre ces démons en
d'Europe aussi nous les connaissons ils
sont aveugles dans la violence et sour
aux appels à la paix moiussi madame la
Première ministre aujourd'hui comment la
France pays ami le médiateur d'un
dialogue pour la paix peut-elle œuvrer
pour que l'espoir né des accords
d'Abraham continue de vivre et pour
empêcher la radicalisation des peuples
face aux menaces je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est à madame la Première ministre merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président François
patria après les attaques terroristes
effroyable mené contre Israël par le
Hamas et le Djihad islamique la France a
immédiatement exprimé sa compassion et
sa solidarité avec le peuple israélien
et condamner fermement ses agressions
nous l'avons dit et je le répète face
aux
terroristes face à une telle attaque une
attaque aussi barbare Israël a le droit
de se
défendre dans cette situation France
tient sa place et nous sommes
particulièrement actifs pour éviter que
le conflit ne dégénère par un
embrasement en 6 Jordani au Liban ou
dans la région le président de la
République s'est entretenu avec de
nombreux homologues parmi lesquels le
président israélien Isaac Herzog et le
Premier ministre Benjamin netaniaahou le
président de l'Autorité palestinienne
Marmoud Abbas le président égyptien si
le président du Conseil libanais Najib
le président émirien Mohamed Ben Zayed
le roi Abdallah de Jordanie et il a eu
des échanges avec le prince héritier
saoudien Mohamed Ben Salman nous allons
poursuivre ces contacts et nous
travaillons à une réponse coordonnée
avec nos alliés occidentaux une réunion
s'est tenue lundi entre le Président de
la République le président américain le
chancelier allemand le Premier ministre
britannique et la présidente du Conseil
italien la ministre des Affaires
étranges Catherine Colona a également
poursuivi ses contacts et une réunion
informelle des ministres des Affaires
étrangères de l'Union européenne s'est
tenu hier j'ajoute que l'ensemble de
notre diplomatie est mobilisé jour et
nuit il est essentiel de poursuivre ces
échanges pour éviter tout risque
d'embrasement mobiliser tous nos
partenaires protéger les civils et
veiller au respect du droit
international monsieur le Président
patria la France restera toujours
attaché à la paix et nous continuerons à
la défendre et à la rechercher comme
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire la
barbarie de ces attaques terribles ne
doit pas nous faire renoncer à trouver
une solution de paix durable au Proche
Orient et une issue politique dans le
conflit
israélo-palestinien nous aurons besoin
d'une approche complète cela prendra du
temps mais nous ne perdons pas de vue
cet objectif c'est le seul chemin pour
la sécurité et la stabilité dans la
région c'est aussi un chemin pour
l'apaisement dans nos démocraties je
vous
remercie la parole est au président
Claude maluré pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et
territoire madame la Première ministre
les images insoutenables de l'attaque
terroriste du Hamas en Israël imposent
une condamnation absolue et une
solidarité totale avec les victimes mais
l'émotion légitime la col et le dégoût
ne doivent pas nous empêcher bien au
contraire de comprendre les raisons pour
lesquelles elles ont pu se produire la
guerre est revenue et nous ne voulons
pas la voir je ne parle pas seulement de
la guerre du Hamas contre Israël mais
des guerres et menace au Moyen-Orient en
Afrique en mer de Chine et maintenant en
Europe c'est la guerre des dictatures
contre les démocraties elle est mondiale
les mains qui ont tranché la gorge des
enfants d'Israël venaient de Gaza mais
le cerveau est attéérant 2008 la
geéorgie 2011 la Syrie 2014 la Crimée
puis le Sahel et l'Ukraine 2023
l'Arménie et aujourd'hui Israël
l'international des dictateurs s'est
reformé nous les avions cru vaincu à la
fin du 20e siècle ils sont de retour
pour mettre à bas les démocraties ils ne
sont pas unis par une idéologie ils sont
une hydre monstrueuse pouvoir mafieux en
Russie dictature du parti à Pyongyang et
Pékin folie islamiste en Iran
soldatesque galoné au sel une solidée
fixe les rassemble renverser à notre
détriment les règles du jeu mondial
comme chaque fois les démocraties sont
aveugles à la catastrophe annoncé pas
parce que leurs ennemis se cachent mais
parce que nous nous voilons la face
l'Europe a construit une formidable
sphère de prospérité mais elle a oublié
qu'il n'y avait pas de prospérité
durable sans puissance et l'Europe
puissance n'existe pas encore ce que
nous devons à toutes les victimes des
attentats en Israël c'est donner un sens
à leur mort c'est qu'il ne soi pas mort
pour rien mais pour nous faire
comprendre que le combat entre les
dictatures et les démocraties est à
nouveau face à nous notre hymne national
nous le dit la liberté liberté chérie ne
peut combattre qu'avec ses défenseur
nous devons nous réarmer militairement
industriellement et surtout surtout
moralement c'est la tâche extrêmement
difficile des gouvernements européens de
votre gouvernement que d'en convaincre
le peuple mais c'est la seule façon
comme nos aînés l'ont fait au siècle
dernier de résister à la
[Applaudissements]
barbarie pour vous
répondre la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le Président Claude
maluré comme vous j'ai été choqué je
l'ai dit desès dimanches par le
relativisme de certains responsables
politiques et leur ambiguité face à ces
actes monstrueux leur refus répété et
assumé d'appeler terroriste une
organisation pourtant reconnue comme
telle et ma conviction c'est que face au
drames terribles qui frappent
Israël notre de voir c'est de veiller à
l'unité nationale à la cohésion
nationale il ne doit y avoir aucune
ambigué face au terrorisme aucune
ambigué pour dénoncer la
barbarie sur notre sol nous ne
laisserons passer aucun aucun
débordement ni sur la ni sur la voie
publique ni dans l'espace numérique nos
valeurs républicaines ne sont pas
négocia l'antisémitisme ou l'apologie du
terrorisme ne peuvent être toléré sous
unee forme nous ferons preuve de la plus
grande fermeté envers ceux qui veulent
faire de cette attaque le prétexte à des
débordements dans nos rues dans nos
écoles dans nos universités nous serons
inflexibles j'ajoute que nous sommes au
côté des Juifs de France que cette
situation choque et inquiète la
République est avec eux dès samedi le
ministre de l'Intérieur a donné
instruction au préfet de renforcer la
vigilance et la protection des lieux
sensibles et nos services de
renseignement sont à l'œuvre pour
détecter toute menace et je rappelle que
sur proposition de du gouvernement le
Parlement a d'ors et déjà définitivement
adopté deux lois de programmation pour
nos armé pour nos forces de sécurité
intérieure et j'espère que vot votre
assemblée adoptera tout à l'heure la loi
de programmation du ministère de la
Justice nous ne devons pas faire preuve
de naïveté nous devons assurer notre
notre souveraineté stratégique
industrielle sur tous les plans monsieur
le Président marluré je le redis dans
ces heures graves la seule solution
celle qui protège la démocratie et nos
valeurs c'est la cohésion nationale
c'est la défense de la République
collectivement l'heure est à la
responsabilité à l'unité c'est ainsi que
nous serons à la hauteur je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame la
présidente Marie scarer pour le groupe
du Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la Première ministre le RDSE
souhaitait s'associer aux autres groupes
du Sénat qui au travers de le leurs
interventions ont exprimé leur stupeur
et leur souffrance ressenti à l'annonce
des attaques terroristes du Hamas en
Israël nous tenons à exprimer toute
notre solidarité et notre tristesse aux
familles et aux proches de ces milliers
de victimes innocentes sauvagement
assassiné ou pris en otage de telles
atrocités engagent la conscience de la
société toute entière et il ne peut-être
laissé de place à la nuance et à la
polémique ces derniers jours une fois de
plus les bombes ont suivi les obus et
les morts ont fait place à d'autres
morts de peuples souffrent et vont
souffrir bien que cela soit prématuré au
regard de l'escalade qui risque de se
jouer aux abords de Gaza il faudra
rapidement interroger les
responsabilités de chacun dans un
processus de paix à l'arrêt si si
certains rapprochements ont laissé
entrevoir une évolution potentiellement
favorable je pense à celui entre
l'Arabie Saoudite et Israël force de
constater que le drame d'aujourd'hui
oblige à repartir d'une page blanche
clairement nous ne devons pas fermer les
yeux en espérant que le temps et la
nécessité face le travail à notre place
aussi madame la Première ministre
quelles seront demain la position et
l'action de la France au sein de la
communauté internationale pour aider les
peuples Israéliens et Palestiniens à
vivre en paix au-delà de cet évén
insoutenable comment accélérer de
concerts avec tous les pays concernés
par le terrorisme dont la France la
lutte contre ce mal récurrent je
terminerai par un extrait du livre de
Yasmin akadra dans les irondelles de
Kabou qui disait zunira s'est égaré le
temps d'une hystérie collective parce
que les horreurs quotidiennes s'avèrent
plus fortes que l'éveil son geste est la
preuve que tout peut basculer sans crier
gare ces mots ne parlent pas d'Israël ou
de la Palestine mais il relate avec
force la fragilité de la paix la
puissance de l'horreur et le danger
permanent de la folie terroriste
aujourd'hui le groupe RDSE souhaitait
juste rappeler cela un hommage à Yael
Lian et noya tombé au kibuts bereri le 7
octobre 2023 et à tous les victimes de
ces attentats je vous
remercie madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la présidente Marie
scarer le drame que vit Israël nous
touche
profondément le bilan de cette attaque
terroriste et grave choquant dans ce
contexte nous sommes au côté du peuple
israélien Israël a le droit de se
défendre face au terrorisme aussi nous
prenons toute notre part et le président
de la République et la ministre des
Affaires étrangères multiplie les
échanges pour permettre la désescalade
et éviter tout embrasement
régional à plus long terme notre
position n'a pas changé nous croyons
dans une paix durable et une solution
politique au conflit la France jouera
pleinement son
rôle madame la Présidente au moment où
le droit international est contesté où
les puissances cherchent à s'affirmer
par tous les moyens où les désordres du
monde se multiplie nous devons assurer
notre sécurité
collective la France est mobilisée nous
continuerons à nous battre pour nos
valeurs nous continuerons à défendre le
respect du droit international des
frontières nous continuerons à renforcer
notre souveraineté en France avec des
moyens inédits pour nos armées et nos
services de renseignement comme en
Europe en défendant la souveraineté
stratégique européenne nous continuerons
aussi à défendre le multilatéralisme et
l'aide au développement nous agissons
avec un seul but des résultats concret
sur le terrain madame la Présidente
carer face au terrorisme comme pour
défendre nos valeurs la France agit et
nous continuons à répondre présent je
vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie la parole est maintenant au
président Bruno rotillot pour le groupe
des
[Applaudissements]
Républicains monsieur le Président
Madame la première ministre
rien rien de ce qui est inhumain ne doit
nous être étranger et aujourd'hui tous
nous nous sentons tous israéliens nous
nous sentons tous aussi Arméniens deux
peuples qui sont liés dans la destinée
tragique par deux génocides dans le
Caucase du Sud les plans du satrave de
Bakou ont réussi sans quasiment aucune
opposition si ce n'est quelques
gesticulation d'abord un blocus pour
affamer une population pendant de longs
mois dans le hautkarabak et puis ensuite
le coup de grâce le coup de grâce pour
achever le travail et jeter sur les
routes d'un exode définitif d'un exode
sans retour près de 110000
arménien 3000 ans presque de présence
arménienne 3 3000 ans d'histoire balayé
effacé en 3 jours madame la Première
ministre mes questions sont précises et
je sais que vos réponses le seront la
première la première pour vous cette
opération de nettoyage est-elle une
épuration ethnique et puis puisque
désormais l'Arménie est menacée dans sa
souveraineté quelle mesure comptez-vous
prendre pour la protéger et en
particulier comptez-vous dénoncer
l'accord cééra de Bakou qu'à signé
Madame Van
derleen en dépit des sanctions puisqu'on
sait que ce gaz vient pour partie de
Moscou merci de vos
réponses pour vous répondre la parole
est à madame la Première ministre merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Bruno
Raillot le sud Caucase est touché par
des événements d'une immense gravité et
le contexte et l'horreur que nous
connaissons depuis samedi ne doivent pas
nous le faire oublier en quelques jours
des familles ont dû quitter leur maisons
et leur terre ancestral un exode massif
de plus de 100000 Arméniens du
hautkarabach a été
organisé monsieur le Président retaillot
je connais votre attachement à l'Arménie
et à la défense du peuple arménien et
comme vous je partage l'émotion et le
choc face à ce drame dès le début la
France a été en première ligne nous
avons fermement condamné l'attitude de
l'Azerbaïdjan la ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères s'est rendu à
Erevan le 3 octobre nous apportons notre
plein soutien politique aux autorités
arméniennes pour que leur intégrité
territoriale leur souveraineté et
l'inviolabilité de leurs frontières ne
soit à aucun moment remise en question
sur le plan humanitaire nous avons
triplé notre aide afin d'aider l'Arménie
à accueillir les milliers de réfugiés du
haut
carabach comme l'a dit le président de
la République à Grenade nous soutenons
le renforcement de la coopération de
l'Union européenne avec
l'Arménie monsieur le Président
rotaillot je le rappelle le président
azerbaïdjanais avait pris l'engagement
clair de ne pas faire usage de la force
dans le haut carabak c'était à Prague en
octobre 2022 lors de la première réunion
de la comité la communauté politique
européenne force de constater que cet
engagement n'a pas été tenu pour sortir
de cette crise nous nous plaidons bien
sûr pour que l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïjan
se parle une réunion se se tiendra d'ici
la fin du mois à Bruxelles sous l'git de
Charles Michel nous serons extrêmement
vigilants quant à l'attitude qui tiendra
le président alief ces discussions
doivent permettre de parvenir à un
accord de paix respectueux du droit
international nous ne transigerons pas
sur ce point enfin tout en écartant
toute logique d'escalade nous avons
renforcé notre coopération de défense
avec l'Arménie et je vous confirme que
nous avons décidé d'autoriser la
fourniture de matériel militaire pour
que l'Arménie soit en mesure d'assurer
sa défense ainsi que l'a indiqué le
président de la République hier nous
voulons continuer à échanger avec les
acteurs pour protéger au mieux l'Arménie
et appeler l'Azerbaïdjan à la
responsabilité je vous
remercie
président arrêtez madame la Première
ministre de mettre sur le même plan le
bourreau et la victime l'Arménie et les
aerbjan le 21 février prochain le
président de la République fera rentrer
au Panthéon missac
Manouchian un orphelin du génnocide
arménien et il y entrera dans ce temple
de la gloire nationale accompagné de son
terrible cortège de ses frères d'armes
tout ce qui était comme l'a dit et écrit
Aragon des Français de préférence qui
avait rejoint la Résistance il y
rentrera aussi accompagné de cet
épouvantable clameur anonyme de toutes
ces vies broyé oublié écrasé par le
génocide et qui du fond de leur tombe
nous demande vous demande implore la
protection de la France pour le peuple
d'aujourd'hui et bien quand le président
de la République au moment même où il
fera son discours il célébrera
l'héroïsme le courage de missac
manouscian peut-être peut-être
pensera-t-il avec quelques regret
à ce même courage qui aujourd'hui fait
tant défaut pour être à la hauteur de
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire à notre collègue Gilbert lu
devin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le
Président mes interrogations
s'inscrivent dans le prolongement du
propos du président Bruno rotaillon
depuis 4 ans nous attirons l'attention
de l'exécutif sur les menaces des
présidents alief et Erdogan ce dernier
déclarait en 2020 vouloir je cite
continuer d'accomplir la mission de nos
grands-parents il a fallu 24 heur 24 he
à l'Azerbaïdjan pour faire disparaître
et tuer la démocratie d'artsat je tiens
à saluer les actions de solidarité des
diasporas notamment françaises de nos
collectivités territoriales des
fondations et associations je salue
aussi la capacité de mobilisation des
Arméniens de la ville de Goris qui font
temps à de besoins et de détresses je
salue la résolution du Parlement
européen qui souligne entre autres que
les principes internationaux ont été
bafoués par l'Azerbaïjan enfin je salue
madame la ministre vos propos tenus à
Erevan oui la France doit aider
l'Arménie à assurer son intégrité
territoriale notamment en renforçant sa
capacité de défense c'est ce que
suggèrait la deuxème résolution du Sénat
votée il y a 1 an c'est une condition
nécessaire pourutant insuffisante trois
interrogations qu'envisage la France et
son gouvernement pour obtenir la
libération des dirigeants du feu la
République d'artsat arrêté comme
terroristes alors qu'ils ont dirigés
incarnés au cocas Sud les valeurs
démocratiques que nous entendons comme
les nôtres qu'envisage la France sur le
Pr européen pour faire arrêter cette
fourniture de gaz par l'Azerbaïjan gaz
provenant de Russie le temps n'est pas
aux sanctions a déclaré notre président
à Grenade quand sera-t-il temps de
sanctionner et de faire mettre fin à
cette hypocrisie
insupportable pour répondre la parole
est à Madame la Ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères madame
Colona merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs dans
ces jours particulièrement difficiles
pour
l'Arménie nous sommes pleinement
mobilisés à ses côtés et au côté du
peuple arménien madame la Première
ministre a redit notre engagement notre
engagement constant et c'est aussi celui
que nous portons auprès de nos
partenaires au Conseil de sécurité et
jusqu'à yevan où je suis allé en effet
la semaine dernière personne ne fait
autant pour l'Arménie que la France
madame la Première ministre a rempli a
rappelé les les grandes lignes de notre
action pour aider l'Arménie et pour
empêcher toute remise en cause de son
intégrité territoriale et je veux vous
dire que tous les engagements que nous
avons pris seront tenus les 12 millions
d'euros et demi d'aide humanitaire sont
en cours de distribution sur le terrain
à des acteurs engagés auprès des
réfugiés et déplacés en Arménie nous
avons pu évacuer ce weekend quatre
blessés graves qui sont accueillis
désormais dans les structures
hospitalières
d'Île-de-France des discussions sont en
cours madame la Première ministre la
confirmé pour permettre à l'Arménie
d'acquérir du matériel militaire à
vocation défensive
au niveau européen nous avons proposé
avec l'Allemagne un ambitieux plan de
soutien à l'Arménie qui sera évoqué à
notre prochain conseil le 23 octobre
avec notamment l'objectif de renforcer
la mission d'observation européenne dans
ses moyens comme dans son mandat et à
l'ONU enfin monsieur le sénateur après
avoir obtenu une réunion du Conseil de
sécurité demander la libération des
personnes arrêtées rappeler le droit des
Arméniens à vivre dans le haut cararabak
nous nous allons continuer de rappeler
le conseil à ses responsabilités en vue
de progresser vers un projet de
résolution et vous le voyez nous sommes
au côté de l'Arménie et nous ne
permettrons pas que son avenir soit
déterminé par la force ou par la menace
de l'usage de la force je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Marc Philippe dabress pour le groupe les
républicains
depuis plus de 3 ans j'ai régulièrement
interpellé vos prédécesseurs qui se sont
succédés à rythme soutenu d'ailleurs sur
la situation de la construction neuve
dans notre pays pour réclamer en va un
plan d'urgence j'ai même eu un entretien
en tête à tête d'une vingtaine de
minutes avec le président de la
République où j'ai pu mesurer qu'il
avait sous-estimé complètement le
problème cette fois nous y sommes la
construction de logement c'est fondre et
vous avez choisi de regarder ailleurs
pourtant les chiffres que vous venez de
publier sont accablants le pire ratio de
construction neuve par rapport aux
demandes des ménages depuis
1950 à la fin de l'année prochaine
250000 constructions neuvees la moitié
ce qui est nécessaire pour loger nos
compatriotes c'est-à-dire 300000
chômeurs de plus à la fin de l'année
prochaine dans le BTP tous les secteurs
sont en panne depuis la promotion privée
qui ne vont plus rien jusqu'au logement
social que vous avez tué par votre
funeste réforme des allocations logement
en passant par l'accession à la
propriété où les primos accédant ne
peuvent plus primo accéder et au
logement étudiant tout récemment
désormais réservés aux enfants de
famille aisé cette crise touche à la
fois le neuf et l'ancien en particulier
à cause de la bureaucratie de la loi sur
les diagnostics énergéties et de la
loisane elle touche à la fois l'offre et
la demande à cause de la montée
exponentielle des taux d'intérêt quel
que soit le scénario envisagé c'est donc
bien une catastrophe annoncée dont je
vous parle on réponse après de longs
mois de dénis vous votre Ministre de
tutelle monsieur Béchu appelle à un choc
de décentralisation ce n'est pas en
refilant la patate chaude aux
collectivités locales sans plan de
relance que vous allez résoudre le
problème même l'ancien Premier ministre
Édouard Philippe vient de sonner
l'alarme en vous demandant de desserrer
les taux du logement ma question est
donc simple monsieur monsieur le
ministre quand allez-vous vous réveiller
pour éviter la bombe sociale que vous
prédit Édouard
Philippe ENL au ministre délégué chargé
du logement monsieur
verg monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur marcphilippe
dobres la crise du logement aujourd'hui
était prévisible puisqu'on savait
effectivement que le prix du foncier
avait fortement augmenté en traînant les
prix imobilier je rappelle dans
certaines grandes villes plus 200 % de
croissance des prix immobiliers et ça
s'expliquait tout simplement par des
taux extrêmement bas qui sont restés
pendant de nombreuses années plus d'une
quinzaine d'années de taux bas et donc
ces taux très bas sont intégrés
aujourd'hui maintenant dans le prix du
foncier c'est ça qui provoque
aujourd'hui la crise du logement avec la
remontée des taux d'intérêt et le coût
des
matériaux le travail que nous opérons
aujourd'hui avec le gouvernement vise à
travailler sur l'ensemble des éléments
qui permettent de relancer la la de
membre nous avons d'abord travaillé sur
la question du logement social et vous
le savez puisque vous avez dû sans doute
suivre le Congrès HLM la semaine passée
à Nantes nous avons trouvé un accord
avec le mouvement HLM pour pouvoir à la
fois réussir le double objectif de la
relance de la production du logement
social et en même temps tenir le
calendrier des rénovations énergétiques
avec 1,2 milliards apportés par le
gouvernement sur 3 ans pour la
rénovation énergétique avec 6 milliards
de prêt de la caiss des dépôts pour
accompagner cette rénovation énergétique
et de l'autre côté du côté de la
production plus 150 millions de prêt
participatifs de la Caisse des Dépôts 8
milliards de prêt de la Caisse des
dépôts à des taux modifiés cet accord a
été jugé très positif par le mouvement
HLM et permettra je le pense de relancer
à la fois la production et de tenir le
calendrier des rénovations nous
travaillons actuellement sur le pré à
tau zéro et la relance de l'accession à
la
propriété renforçant le dispositif dans
les zones tendues là où il y en a le
plus besoin en le maintenant sur
l'accession sociale dans zones détendue
nous travaillons également sur le
logement locatif intermédiaire et en
particulier la possibilité d'ouvrir aux
institutionnels ce logement locatif
intermédiaire aujourd'hui nous
travaillons sur le foncier Thomas
casaznav l'a évoqué récemment avec la
possibilité de faire un choc d'offre
foncière pour libérer d'avantage de
foncier bref monsieur le sénateur nous
sommes en train de travailler sur
l'ensemble des fondamentaux de la
politique du logement je vous
remercie parole est non non non non vous
n'avez plus de temps la parole à notre
collègue Stéphane de pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste merci monsieur le
Président bonjour madame la ministre des
Affaires
étrangères je sais bien que l'actualité
en chasse une autre et que nos regards
et nos cœurs sont aujourd'hui mobilisés
à quelques exceptions près par le peuple
israélien victime d'une impensable
barbarie
moyenâgeuse je sais bien que le monopoie
Mondial est complexe et que l'Europe au
regard du contexte ukrainien avait
besoin de diversifier ses importations
de gaz ce qui rapporte des milliards à
l'Azerbaïjan nos collègues rotayo et
devinas en ont parlé tout cela nous le
savons néanmoins je souhaite moi aussi
revenir sur la situation dramatique du
haut cararabak comme en Ukraine comme à
Gaza comme dans de nombreux endroits de
la planète la force prévaut sur le droit
faut-il madame la ministre qu'un peuple
disparaisse pour savoir qu'il existe
80 % de la population arménienne a dû
abandonner du jour au lendemain la terre
qu'elle habite depuis 2500 ans pour ne
pas se faire massacrer et ce après avoir
été encerclé et affamé la Russie a
renoncé à protéger l'Arménie et nous
Européens avons poussé le cynisme
jusqu'à inviter le Premier ministre
arménien Nicole pinia a négocié avec ses
agresseurs chacun sait que c'est facile
de négocier avec un couteau sous la
gorge chacun sait que c'est facile de
négocier avec un président qui promet je
cite de vous chasser comme des chiens
charlesdvour incanté dans une de ces
chansons après l'horreur après la peur
pour toi Arménie le monde s'est levé le
monde est avec toi alors madame la
ministre la France est-elle avec
l'Arménie madame la ministre la France
se lève-t-elle pour l'Arménie au-delà
des mots de compassion et au-delà des
condamnations diplomatiques de
circonstances qu'envisage de faire la
France pour le peuple arménien qui a
connu le premier génocide du 20e siècle
et qui vit actuellement sous nos yeux le
premier nettoyage ethnique du 21e
siècle parole est à Madame la Ministre
de l'Europe des Affaires
étrangères merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
chacun bien sûr dans cette hémicycle
mesure la la gravité de la crise qui se
déroule au Proche Orient mais ne saurz
nous faire détourner le regard de la
situation dans le sud Caucase et et en
Arménie en effet quel que soit la
manière dont il cherche à présenter la
situation oui l'Azerbaïjan a planifié et
organisé l'exode de plus de 100000
Arméniens du hakarabach il s'agit d'acte
d'une extrême gravité de CRIM et de
crimes qui ne peuvent rester sans
réaction nous avons organisé un nouveau
débat au Conseil de sécurité nous lui
demandons aujourd'hui de prendre ses
responsabilités pour une résolution qui
permette de créer les conditions d'un
possible retour des populations
arméniennes du ha cararabach cela passe
par des garanties des garanties fermes
du respect de leurs droits historique et
culturel et par une présence
internationale permanente qui est
l'objet de tous nos efforts madame la
Première ministre a rappelé tout à
l'heure et je l'ai fait à sa suite
l'ensemble de ce que nous faisons pour
aider l'Arménie je le redis comme aucun
autre pays ne le fait not conviction
comme l'a dit la première ministre c'est
bien que les questions en suspens entre
l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïjan ne pourront
trouver de solution que par un un
processus négocié et par une paix juste
et durable c'est la raison pour laquelle
la France soutient les efforts de
médiation de l'Union européenne soutien
qui est un soutien exigeant qui ne fera
aucune concession sur le nécessaire
respect du droit international de la
souveraineté et de l'intégrité
territoriale de l'Arménie et en
parallèle oui nous devons continuer de
soutenir l'Arménie comme nous le faisons
et de disuader l'Azerbaïjan avec
quelques messages qui lui sont adressés
y compris ceux qui a été confirmé
aujourd'hui
le dissuader de poursuivre dans la voie
de la force il n'y a pas d'alternative
possible pour assurer la paix au
bénéfice de toutes les population dans
le sud Caucase je vous
remercie il vous restait
quelqu la parole est à notre collègue
Christine
bonantisa pour le groupe des
républicain merci merci monsieur le
président monsieur le garde des vous
nêtes pas sansignorer la situation d'une
grande majorité des agents du GREF
partout en France qui estim que leur
légitime revendication n'est pas prise
en compte et je sais que vous vous en
préoccupez mais après votre récent
déplacement à Grenoble il demeure
encore des des divergences entre leurs
revendication et cell des
syndicats cette profession mise à rue
d'épreuve depuis déjà fort longtemps
réclame finalement une réforme forme
indispensable à son statut catégoriel
une revalorisation en conséquence
salariale en conséquence mais également
une meilleure reconnaissance de sa
fonction au sein de l'institution
judiciaire ces
négociations visent simplement à
rééquilibrer leur statut en fonction des
deux autres directions de votre
ministère ce qu'il demande en réalité
monsieur le ministre c'est une réforme
d'équité mais au fond cette situation
n'est que le reflet des difficultés de
recrutement que rencontre la fonction
publique et plus particulièrement des
ministères régaliens qui n'ont pas su
enrayer la démotivation d'un nombre
important d'agents et ce n'est pas le
recours fréquent à des agents
contractuels qui va leur redonner
confiance alors monsieur le ministre
vous savez combien le Sénat est attaché
à cette fonction nous avons uvré avec
force pour la trajectoire de recrutement
de 1800 gr
pouvez-vous me dire alors où en sont
réellement ces négociations et quand
est-ce qu'elles vont enfin
aboutir la parole est à monsieur le
garde d saau monsieur Dupont Moretti
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Bonfanti d'sage je tout
d'abord vous féliciter de façon
républicaine et chaleureuse pour votre
réélection ainsi que pour l'élection où
la élection de toutes les sénatrices et
sénateurs votre question madame la
sénatrice me permet de rafler une fois
encore qu'il a pas de justice sans
greffier depuis 2022 un greffier en
milieu de carrière a bénéficié d'une
augmentation de
294 € brut mensuel soit plus 13 % de sa
rémunération mais mais ça n'est pas
suffisant j'avais annoncé dans un
calendrier dédié à l'automne un certain
nombre de mesures nouvelles mais comme
vous le dites et vous avez raison il y a
un certain nombre de divergences entre
les greffiers eux-mêmes sur ce qu'ils
souhaitent et dans l'expression des
différents syndicats qui viennent au
soutien de leurs intérêts alors les axes
de discussion et le protocole d'accord
contiendra trois axes en réalité
revalorisation statutaire des greffiers
de catégorie B+ ça doit intervenir fin
2023 création d'un corps de greffier de
catégorie A c'est inédit ça concerne 25
% du
corps enfin un plan de requalification
des agents de catégorie C faisant
fonction de greffier ce qui permettra à
700 agents de catégorie C de devenir
greffier et de reconnaître ainsi
l'expérience qu'ils ont acquise je vous
annonce madame la sénatrice que je
souhaite signer ce protocole avec les
syndicats d'ici une quinzaine de jours
je souhaite également hardemment que le
Sénat dans quelques minutes adopte la
lobgie ce qui nous permettra bien sûr
d'envoyer dans les juridictions 1800
greffi de plus et concernant agin ville
qui vous tient particulièrement à cœur
j'ai demandé au directeur des services
judiciaires de se déplacer demain pour
rencontrer les greffiers et leur faire
part des évolutions qui sont en
cours merci merci Monsieur le gardessau
pour ces paroles encourageantes
j'accepte l'augure qu'ell rassureront
tous les agents du GREF afin qu'il n'y
ait plus d'injustice dans la
justice
mer la parole est à notre collègue
Colomb brossell pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste
eté merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Éducation
nationale ma question porte sur le bilan
de votre rentrée scolaire car derrière
votre plan de communication permanent il
y a des chiffres des constats des
réalités et ils sont cruels cruels pour
vous mais surtout cruel pour les élèves
leurs enseignants les personnels
éducatifs qui on paient tous le prix
cette rentrée scolaire c'est la rentrée
de l'impréparation c'est la rentrée des
engagements non tenu fin août vous
annonciez un professeur devant chaque
classe il n'en est rien dans des
académies entières des enseignants ont
été nommés et affectés plusieurs jours
après la rentrée quittant du jour au
lendemain leurs classes et leurs élèves
pour aller retrouver leur affectation
définitive de même des milliers de
lycéens souvent en voie professionnelle
ou technologiqu attendent encore le 11
octobre une
affectation enfin alors que 288000
enfants en situation de handicap
scolarisé en milieu ordinaire ont besoin
d'un accompagnement la moitié d'entrex
n'a aucun accompagnement le 3 octobre
dernier les aesh étaient d'ailleurs en
grève voilà un tableau bien noir face à
des urgences qui s'accumulent alors
monsieur le ministre que répondez-vous
aux parents et aux élèves qui font face
à la chaise vide de leur enseignants aux
enseignants qui méritent plus que des
primes conditionnées à l'exercice de
mission complémentairire ou aux aesh qui
veulent enfin être reconnus pour leur
travail
indispensable la parole est au ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse Monsieur
hatal Merci monsieur monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice vous abordez la rentrée
scolaire dans votre question et pour
vous répondre je voudrais commencer vous
n'avez pas jugé bon de le faire par
remercier et saluer les enseignants les
chefs d'établissements les agents
d'érectorat qui ont organisé cette
rentrée au service des élèves et des
familles madame la sénatrice évidemment
il y a des
difficultés évidemment qu'il y a oui
c'est vrai des difficultés dans notre
système scolaire
simplement je veux rappeler quelques
réalités la première réalité c'est que
depuis
2017 il y a 300000 élèves de moins dans
notre système scolaire et que si on
avait suivi cette démographie on aurait
supprimé autour de 20000 postes on en a
créé 2000 300000 élèves de moins 2 2000
postes en plus 300000 élèves de moins
depuis 2017 et pourtant une augmentation
du budget de 30 % ça ne s'était jamais
vu dans les précédents quinquena oui il
y a des difficultés mais nous
investissons comme jamais pour
l'éducation nationale vous avez abordé
le la rémunération des enseignants oui
c'était dû cette revalorisation des
enseignants mais elle n'est pas comme
vous l'avez dit conditionnée à des
missions supplémentaire tous les
enseignants ont connu une revalorisation
sans contrepartie encore à cette rentrée
si vous comparez la rentrée 2022
septembre 2022 à septembre 2023 c'est
entre 125 et 250 € nets de plus pour
tous les enseignants de rentré à rentré
entre le point d'indice et la
revalorisation chocle qui a eu lieu en
cette rentrée vous parlez de l'école
inclusive et des AES nous avons
quasiment doublé le nombre d'élèves qui
sont accueillis à l'école et nous avons
recruté 40000 AES nous les revalorisons
de 13 % encore en cette rentrée
évidemment on n'est pas au bout des
problèmes on doit maintenant améliorer
qualitativement l'accueil des élèves et
c'est le travail qu'on a engagé avec mes
collèges Fadila catabi aurant berger
pour continuer à avancer oui il y a des
difficultés mais oui nous investissons
comme jamais et je suis absolument
convaincu que nous viendront au bout de
ces difficultés avec les enseignants
avec les chefs d'établissements les aesh
avec les familles parce que nous voulons
tous je le crois la réussite de notre
école au service de nos élèves madame
Brossel merci monsieur le Président j'ai
trop de respect pour cette assemblée
pour céder à la démagogie alors Tom
Jasmine Abdrahman et Louise ce sont des
enfants qui n'ont pas fait leur rentrée
car ce sont des enfants en situation de
handicap qui ne sont pas rentrés à
l'école en cette rentrée Guillaume Abdel
fatumata sont des lycéens qui n'ont pas
fait leur rentrée parce qu'ils n'ont pas
eu d'affectation à cette rentrée et tant
que le gouvernement considérera que ce
sont des sujets de statistique et bien
nous nous continuerons à porter la
parole de ces enfants de ses élèves
partout et y compris dans cet
[Applaudissements]
hémicycle parole est à notre collègue
Vivette Lopez pour le groupe les
républicains merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues j'associe à ma question
mon collègue Alain Châtillon
monsieur le ministre je suis très
surprise enfin je ne devrais pas depuis
le temps je dirais plutôt scandalisé de
constater qu'en France lorsque l'on est
vertueux que l'on est prudent et économe
l'état beaucoup moins vertueux n'hésite
pas à venir se servir pour en récupérer
les fruits et c'est ce que vous vous
apprêtez à faire avec les retraite
complémentaire agir
Arco les réserves accumulées ont été
constitué par un effort soutenu des
salariés et sont le fruit d'une gestion
raisonnable elles assurent sur le long
terme la retraite des salariés du privé
faute de conduire des réformes
courageuses pour ramener les finances
publiques à l'équilibre vous allez pour
la deuxième fois piller les caisses de
l'agir àco ces réserves n'appartiennent
donc pas à votre gouvernement aussi
Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous nous
rassurer et nous garantir que les
réserves financières de ces régimes
émentaire ne feront pas l'objet d'un
prélèvement
indu ministre du Travail du plein emploi
deinertion monsieur
Lop merci monsieur le président madame
la sénatrice vous m'interrogez sur la
caisse complémentaire à Carco et sur les
perspectives financières de celle-ci
d'abord je voudrais vous rejoindre sur
un point cette caisse est bien gérée
elle est bien gérée puisquelle dégage
des excédents et elle dégage elle dégage
d'autant plus d'excédent que depuis 2019
parce que cela a été voté par les
partenaires sociaux une décote une
décote temporaire de 10 % est appliquée
et plus d'un salarié sur deux parti à la
retraite depuis 2019 et bénéficiant de
cette que de retraite a été touché par
la décotte nous avons présenté la
réforme des retraites avec madame la
Première ministre il y a quelques mois à
tous les toutes les étapes de la
concertation nous avons dit aux
partenaires sociaux que cette réforme
était une réforme de retour à
l'équilibre tout régime confondu nous
savons aujourd'hui que la girir CARK va
continuer à dégager des excédents et et
nous savons qu'à horizon 2026 parmi les
excédents sur le total des excédents et
nous ne parlons surtout pas des réserves
mais uniquement des excédents annuels
sur le total des excédents 2026 1
milliard 2 d'excédents sont dus à la
réforme des retraites qui a été adopté
au printemps
dernier nous considérons qu'il y a
1illard2 million d'euros qui vont
bénéficier à GIR Carco en 2026
uniquement par la réforme et nous
considérons comme légitime que cette
part des excédents liés à la réforme
puisse être mobilisé pour participer
au financement d'un régime de solidarité
les partenaires sociaux ont mis en œuvre
une discussion sur les règles de gestion
de laag Carco et on fait un choix
différent choix différent qui se traduit
au même horizon 2026 par une
augmentation des dépenses sociales et
donc des dépenses publiques au sens de
la loi organique d'un milliard d'euros
supplémentaires nous nous devons faire
face donc à deux défis le premier défi
c'est voir comment nous pouvons
rééquilibrer les finance publi pour
faire face à un milliard d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires et nous
considérons que ça n'est pas une
attitude totalement responsable nous
devons faire face à un second défi qui
est de garantir que la réforme que vous
avez voté qui est mise en œuvre soit une
réforme de retour à l'équilibre du
régime de
retraite
Lop monsieur le ministre sachez que ce
prélèvement est perçu comme un raquette
la solidarité financière n'est pas
entendable ce n'est pas au retraité du
privé de payer le gaspillage de l'État
en outre la ponction demandée par l'État
met en danger la pérennité des retraites
complémentaires et l'Aven des relations
sociales aussi si d'aventure le
gouvernement passait par la loi de
financement de sécurité sociale pour en
obtenir le versement nous serons là et
nous engagerons notre responsabilité
pour garantir l'avenir des relations
sociales et la pérennité des retraite
complémentaire la parole est à notre
collègue
maridoliman pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre des solidarités et des familles
le dynamisme de la natalité française a
longtemps été une exception un modèle or
comme sur tant d'autres sujets la France
décline depuis 2011 la natalité est en
chute libre dans notre pays et vous
regardez ailleurs l'INC vient
malheureusement de confirmer une
nouvelle fois une nouvelle baisse de la
natalité et 2023 pourrait être la pire
année depuis 1945 avec seulement 700000
naissances les raisons on les connaît
c'est d'abord le démantelllement de la
politique familiale sous François
Hollande baisse du cootient familial de
la
page modulation des allocations en
fonction des revenus parentaux
plafonnement des ressources congé
parental insuffisant depuis 2017 malgré
diverses annonces rien n'a été fait pour
soutenir les familles et leur redonner
confiance promesse de créer des places
en crèche rendu veine par l'étranglement
financier des communes manque de
personnel qualifié gelle des prestations
familiales au fond avec la fin de
l'universalité la politique familiale
est devenue une politique
essentiellement sociale qui ne compense
plus la charge de l'entretien et de
l'éducation de l'enfant parce
qu'accueillir un enfant engage et dépend
de la façon dont on se projette dans
l'avenir emploi logement sécurité
financière anxiété climatique c'est
aujourd'hui votre responsabilité alors
si cette chute de la natalité nous
inquiète elle devrait vous obséder ce
qui est en jeu ce n'est ni plus ni moins
que la survie de la France car relever
le défi de la natalité c'est bien sûr
préserver notre modèle social c'est
faire perdurer notre culture et notre
identité c'est aussi et surtout rester
maître de notre destin national au vu de
tous ces enjeux la politique familiale
devrait redevenir une priorité nationale
madame la ministre je sais que vous
partagez peu auou prou ces constats
alors que comptez-vous faire pour
concrètement enrayer le déclin
démograque démographique de la France à
quand une vraie politique familiale
généreuse ambitieuse qui soutient toutes
les familles et renoue avec notre
histoire notre modèle je vous
remercie ministre des Solidarités et des
familles madame Aurore
berger merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice et permettez-moi de
vous féliciter pour votre
élection les mots que vous avez tenus je
pourrais les reprendre pas peu ou prou
les reprendre intégralement parce que
vous avez raison la baisse de laalité
dans notre pays elle devrait tous en
fait nous obséder parce que quand on
parle des grandes transitions qui sont
devant nous la transition évidemment
écologique et énergétique il y a aussi
la question de la transition
démographique nous avons d'un côté le
choc démographique devant nous la
question du vieillissement de la
population mais nous ne pouvons pas
avoir dans le même temps ce risque de
baisse de la natalité que nous
constatons comme vous l'avez relevé
depuis 2011 et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous devons réaffirmer ce que
doit être la politique familiale dans
notre pays une politique familiale
universelle au service de toutes les
familles et qui vient donc en soutien de
la démographie et de la natalité c'est
ça l'objectif même de la politique
familiale qui a été créée et pensé dans
l'après-gerre et avec laquelle nous
devons évidemment renouer en tout cas
c'est l'objectif qui m'a été confié par
le Président de la République et par la
première ministre alors qu'est-ce que
nous devons faire vous l'avez dit nous
devons agir à la fois sur les
prestations familiales pour qu'avant
corriger avant de corriger les inégalité
elle soit en soutien de l'ensemble
évidemment des familles de notre pays
nous devons agir sur les freins
périphériques évidents qui continuent à
exist qui font qu'aujourd'hui le désir
d'enfants dans notre pays n'est pas en
adéquation avec le nombre d'enfants que
les Français ont et cela a des causes
des causes sanitaires c'est la question
de l'infertilité qui ne doit plus être
un tabou dans notre pays mais sur lequel
nous devons avoir une véritable
politique c'est la question de la garde
d'enfants parce qu'aujourd'hui nous le
savons trop de familles n'arrivent pas à
réaliser leur désir d'enfant parce
qu'ils sont angoissés sur ce sujet c'est
la réforme que nous souhaitons porter
notamment vous le savez sur la question
du congé parental pour faire en sorte
que les familles a plus de temps avec
leurs enfants bref c'est un chantier
majeur que nous devons ouvrir et que
j'espère bien pouvoir ouvrir avec vous
madame la
sénatrice merci la parole est à Monsieur
ravier pour la Réunion administrative
des sénateurs de figurants sur la liste
d'aucun groupe vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Intérieur le
Hamas c'est une organisation terroriste
fondée par la confréie des Frères
musulmans en France comme en Israël il
massacre sans pitié hommes femmes et
enfants ces Frères musulmans qui vivent
parmi nous à cause de la folle politique
d'immigration que vous avez tous soutenu
ici mes chers collègues par faiblesse ou
par conviction il faut les traiter comme
en Israël par une réplique radicale et
impitoyable
si certains s'y refusent moi je le dis
clairement ma haine ils l'ont cette
guerre nous a été déclarée par les
islamistes depuis des années il y a 10
ans déjà un de leurs soldats assassiné
des enfants dans une école juive et des
militaires à Toulouse et à Montauban
depuis des jeunes des caricaturistes des
prêtres des femmes libres des policiers
un professeur ont été massacrés sur
notre sol ils assassinent méthodiquement
et froidement tous ceux qui font la
France tout ce qui fait notre
civilisation car c'est bien d'une guerre
de civilisation dont il s'agit ici comme
à Marseille je dénonce depuis des années
les conséquences de votre
immigrationnisme les activités des
islamistes dans ma ville de ces mosquées
assujetti aux Frères musulmans jusqu'au
collège financé par l'Arabie Saoudite
qu'en avez-vous fait monsieur le
ministre rien il continue de prospérer
grâce à l'immigration massive et à sa
natalité toujours plus conquérante alors
puisqu'en matière d'antisémitisme et
plus globalement en matière de
protection de tous les Français monsieur
le ministre vous êtes censé ne rien
laisser passer allez-vous dissoudre les
Frères musulmans et tous les organismes
toutes les mosqu toutes les associations
qui se réclament de cette pensée et à
cette réplique immédiate il faut une
politique de fond allez-vous enfin non
seulement stopper mais aussi inverser le
courant de l'immigration une immigration
qui alimente on le sait le soutien du
Hamas chez nous allez-vous expulser tous
les étrangers qui soutiennent le Hamas
allez-vous ordonner la dissolution de
tous les collabos du Hamas des Indigènes
de la République on NPA de la CGT 13 au
syndicat Sud en passant par
l'organisation de la jeunesse des
communistes de mon département pourtant
sous d'un de nos collègues monsieur by
allez-vous mettre hors d'état de nuire
cette 5è colonne car chez nous monsieur
le ministre la gangraine est déjà
partout et la gangraine on l'élimine ou
on en
crève pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'Intérieur Monsieur
dorbenin Merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur ravier peut-être
pourrions-nous dans ce moment si
terrible pour nos compatri ot ceux qui
vivent dans leur chair les attaques
terroristes du Hamas en Israël ceux qui
s'inquiètent pour leur famille pour nos
compatriotes de confession juif bien
évidemment qui sont sur lere territoire
national don je rappelle que c'est la
première communauté d'Europe et la
troisème communauté juive du monde
peut-être que nous pourrions tous en
tant que responsable politique et ça
s'adresse autant qu'à vous que à LFI de
ne pas faire autant de parallèles
politiciens pour importer chez nous le
conflit désastreux ignoble qui touche
les Israéliens peut-être là reste une
phrase d'abord de responsable politique
plutôt que d'essayer de vivre des
problèmes comme vous le faites
manifestement peut-être qu'un peu de
dessence quand des bébés quand des
femmes quand des vieillards sont
massacrés pourriez-vous arrêter quelques
instants de faire des traxs pour
Monsieur éc
Zemour nous en avons terminé avec les
questions au Gouvernement merci mesdames
et messieurs les ministres les
prochaines questions d'actualité auront
lieu le mercredi 18 octobre à 15h la
séance sera reprise à à
16h45 pour les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire sur le projet
de loi d'orientation et de programmation
du ministère de la Justice ainsi que la
commission mixte paritaire sur le projet
de loi relatif à l'ouverture à la
modernisation et à la responsabilité du
corps judiciaire notre séance est
suspendue